telling me that i could do it
i would love to okay questions would you
do it would you do it at 35 with a kid
no
what if what if what if okay i don't
know
right now
i don't think i could just because i
just feel like i would just want to be
loved and loved loved by one person and
i would want to give that to him all
your bills are being taken care of but
the bills might not matter necessarily
yeah each individual realistically most
people it will but say all your boxes
are ticked everything whatever that is
to you everything's ticked but you've
got it i think
one box would be that like i would want
you that's what i'm saying call it
selfish i would want you for myself and
then i know me i'm just gonna get
jealous i'm just gonna be upset so
there's no point okay so by this logic
do you guys believe that sex is a duty
yes yes hundred percent yeah do you guys
believe a man has a right to cheat if
you say no to sex
no right is this not wait wait no no no
no contextualize
okay so if he says i want to have sex
you say no he says okay so if you're not
going to have sex with me i'll find
someone who will consistently if he's
like if he's saying it with that vim
then i'll respect him because he's
telling me what he's going to do but if
he's like he's just gone to cheat and
he's come back and he's like oh you
didn't want to have sex with me so i did
this i'd be like that's disrespectful do
you just want to yes or no are you on
your period maybe you've had a like like
are there things because women that
don't give sex that i think that's very
mad because if a girl is continually
sexless does he have a right to cheat he
would yeah but there's a reason for
everything if you're in a relationship
or marriage and you're not happy or
fulfilled or you're not fulfilling your
partner there's a reason people don't
just do things you have no reason yeah
okay but the reason typically is that
she didn't marry the guy she wanted she
needed kids then she should so that yeah
but
what does he have to do no but i'm
saying she doesn't she knows she can't
do better she knows time's running out
she's she's around 30 right time's taken
she wants kids she she marries the first
guy she can find if she's smart if she's
smart she knows he's doing it anyway but
he he doesn't know because a lot of
times this isn't the guys that can cheat
he doesn't know that she's marrying her
second choice the same way will didn't
know
there were some warning signs but
yeah yeah she cried on the wedding day
on the wedding day yeah yeah
yeah you know what he's not a great
example
a lot
a lot of guys don't know they're a
girl's second choice but if you're her
friend you you know
you're like you guys know your girl's
dating a guy she doesn't really want
you know and those are the guys that
don't get the sex
and then the girls are come back
heartbroken when he or you know now
they're mad when he cheats but like she
wasn't sleeping with him to begin with
i just feel like people should have
conversations
like for me it's just the logic have a
conversation
okay
i agree with you but put yourself in
their shoes okay so so you let's say
you're married to a girl again you don't
know that you are her second choice she
stops sleeping with you after she gets
what she wants the kids
now what could you do you could leave
but you put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage you possibly
could like they're more likely to go to
prison they're more likely to run away
they're more likely to fail out of
school every statistical disadvantage
you could put your could at that that's
your choice
option two is to divorce her
and she you're she's entitled to child
support she can get collect alimony and
in the u.s like she can literally take
half your [ __ ]
and your third option is you know what
i'm gonna just cheat
you know i'm gonna die if i if if i'm to
put myself in a guy's perspective yeah i
would just think what is my game not
that good then put up probably go cheap
100 because that's the easier safer
option and pray that she don't find out
yeah
so that's why guys do it a lot of the
time i'm not saying some some guys are
just cheaters like those that's just
they're going to do that regardless but
like that's a lot of times when guys
cheat it's because their wife isn't
giving them anything i've had guys send
me stories where they're they like don't
know what to do because they love their
wife they want to be with their wife but
she won't sleep with him it's been a
year what is it
that's mad do you think men marry the
person they love or who's ready when
they're ready
i think it's who's ready when they're
already but at the like partially but at
the same time men and women love
different because i think men can love
more than one girl at a time
where where women can only love one at a
time
and she has to view that guy as like the
best that she could get and if she feels
like that like this guy was the best i
could do like he'll be in her head
forever
like i had a comment section when i was
explaining this concept there was a
woman who was 80 that said there was a
guy that she met when she was 21 that
she still thinks about every day
wow yeah i'm trying to do that
[Laughter]
wait do you guys agree with the
statements i was talking to one girl one
time she said um
she's in a 14-year relationship so i
said you know your man's probably like
cheating like every night and again
and she said to me
as long as i'm happy and he doesn't
bring that nonsense home
that is fine so do you agree with that
statement i've heard this by from
several women
in this day and age because everybody
the pressure is getting you know what
the problem with cheating is it's it's
not the action is people being reckless
it's the whole so just did i use the
condom
what if he's not what i'm saying if he
said well i use the condom though would
you be like
sometimes it's not what you say is how
you say wait is it 14 years of marriage
or of a relationship because i feel like
like she's you to get married but then
she just said if i'm happy in this
relationship and you've never given me
any reason to doubt you even though i
know you're a man and probably do it as
long as i never find out
and i'm happy let's be honest i feel
like a lot of women are not accepting
that anyway a lot of women are in
situations where they've just accepted
would you not accept that though are you
happy to live by that standard
what like the whole outside out of mind
yeah but it's just i think i've never i
think we do it anyway we do it anyway
women do that if i ain't seen nothing i
ain't quote you
and i think it
like
but if you know they could probably
gonna do it anyway why is it such a
madness when it does get caught but
that's all emotions that's a different
like you have to delve deeper because
that's emotions that's impossible no no
i'm saying like if you know that he's
gonna do it anyway like why is it a big
deal when he gets caught wait are we
saying that oh man cheat is that is that
what was it walking off the premise
the man that you're attracted to the man
that most women are attracted to will
probably cheat at some point in let's
say you're gonna be married for 40 to 60
years of your life at some point this
guy's going to step out yeah so you all
know what happened if you do buy
whatever circumstance you catch the guy
cheating
in your mind you already know he's an
attractive man he's got options he's
loyal the majority of the time and i
expect this to happen why is it still a
madness can i ask you a question if you
cheat on a woman and she doesn't react
what do you think what are you going to
think if she doesn't really scare it if
she don't really if she don't react if
she finds out you've cheated and she's
like okay cool that's based on what is
inside not about opportunity it's
would you be like this is i gotta wipe
her now
or like she she's about to kill me next
time let me let me run it's about to do
some spiteful [ __ ] that's what i'm
thinking
the reaction the reaction is natural
so the reaction means that that's what
i'm talking about i think about this
context because i look at my parents for
example
my dad stepped out of my mom a couple
times but my mom knew that it was she
she knew it wasn't a thing but this is
this is like when they were younger she
knew like mendel would be men because in
nigeria they knew what men were like so
it wasn't a big deal and the men knew it
wasn't a big deal so that's how society
functioned in today's society we know
that women are hyper sensitive so i
expect a reaction because that's that's
what the society teaches but in reality
again if you really know what's going to
happen why does it why does it need such
a madness do you get what i'm saying
there's levels of reaction
there's levels like there's going to
instagram i'm posting on your on your
status about like my jordan exactly and
then there's
dealing with him at home and saying you
know what like i'm i'm in the mood right
now and i think some reactions mean that
you care that if you don't react i would
kind of assume i'm saying